>>> BROOLYN NETS KYRIE IRVING
REFUSING TO DETAIL HIS
VACCINATION STATUS TODAY.
>> I'M A HUMAN BEING FIRST AND
OBVIOUSLY, LIVING IN THIS PUB
LIKE SPEAR THERE IS A LOT OF
QUESTIONS WHAT IS GOING ON IN
THE WORLD OF KYRIE AND I WOULD
LOVE TO KEEP THAT PRIVATE AND,
YOU NEXT HANDLE IT THE RIGHT WAY
WITH MY TEAM AND GO FORWARD
TOGETHER WITH THE PLAN.
>> SO IRVING MAKING THAT
STATEMENT REMOTELY SEPARATED
FROM HIS TEAMMATES AND BECAUSE
OF LOCAL RESTRICTIONS, HE CAN'T
PLAY IN HOME GAMES UNLESS
VACCINATED.
KAREEM ABDAL JA BAR IS TALKING
ABOUT IT.
SO KAREEM ABDUL-JABBAR, THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE TONIGHT AND
DOING WHAT YOU DO.
CAN I GET YOUR REACTION TO KYRIE
IRVING'S STATEMENT.
>> I CAN'T ACCEPT KYRIE IRVING'S
STATEMENT.
HE'S HIDING BEHIND PROCEDURE
HERE.
YOU EITHER UNDERSTAND WHAT IS
GOING ON AND YOU DO THE RIGHT
THING OR YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT IS GOING ON AND YOU'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO CREATE ALL
THIS CONFUSION WITH YOUR STANCE.
SO, YOU KNOW, WE GOT TO GET THAT
CLEARED UP EXACTLY WHERE HE
STANDS AND WHAT THAT MEANS TO
THOSE AROUND HIM.
>> SOURCES TELLING CNN THAT
APPROXIMATELY 90% OF NBA PLAYERS
ARE VACCINATED AGAINST COVID-19.
YOU THINK THE 10% SHOULD BE LET
GO?
>> I THINK THEY SHOULD BE
DISCIPLINED.
I DON'T THINK THAT THEY ARE
BEHAVING LIKE GOOD TEAMMATES OR
GOOD CITIZENS.
THIS IS A WAR THAT WE'RE
INVOLVED IN AND MASKS AND
VACCINES, THEY ARE THE WEAPONS
THAT WE USE TO FIGHT THIS WAR
AND WHEN YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE
CORPORATIVE WITH THAT, YOU ARE
WORKING AGAINST THE EFFORT TO
MAKE EVERYBODY SAFE AND, YOU
KNOW, WE CAN'T HAVE THAT.
THAT DOESN'T WORK FOR EVERYBODY.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE FOLKS WHO SAY
HEY, LISTEN, IT'S MY RIGHT AND
FREEDOM AND MY BODY.
I CAN DO WHAT I WANT.
I SHOULDN'T BE TOLD WHAT TO DO.
>> THAT'S FINE BUT THEY DON'T
HAVE TO DO THAT WITHIN THE FRAME
WORK OF THE NBA AND PUT OTHER
PEOPLE AT RISK.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE.
PUTTING OTHER PEOPLE AT RISK,
NOT ABOUT WHETHER SOMEBODY FEELS
MACHO ENOUGH THEY WILL GO
AGAINST THE COVID VIRUS AND NOT
HAVE ANY VACCINATION PROTECTION
AND, YOU KNOW, MAYBE IT MAKES
THEM FEEL BRAVE OR, YOU KNOW,
ABLE TO DO SOMETHING THAT OTHERS
CAN'T DO.
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE SHOULD BE
DOING HERE.
WE SHOULD BE TRYING TO LIMIT
THIS VIRUS WITH ALL THE TOOLS
THAT WE HAVE AT OUR DISPOSAL.
>> I WANT TO PLAY THIS AND SEE
IF YOU REMEMBER.
THIS IS FROM LeBRON JAMES, WATCH
THIS.
>> PREDICATED TO MY FAMILY, YOU
KNOW, FOR THE MAJORITY FOR 99.9%
OF THAT.
SO IT'S ABOUT THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF MY FAMILY AND THAT'S
WHAT IT CAME DOWN TO.
ME BEING AVAILABLE TO MY
TEAMMATES ON THE FLOOR IS ME
TAKING CARE OF MY BODY.
>> DO YOU MIND ME ASKING IF
YOU'RE CONFIRMING YOU DID GET
THE VACCINE?
>> IT'S NOT A BIG DEAL.
>> SO LISTEN, WE HAVEN'T HEARD
FROM LeBRON ABOUT THAT SINCE,
THE LAKERS GENERAL MANAGER SAID
ALL PLAYERS ON THE ROSTER WILL
BE FULLY VACCINATED FOR THE NEW
SEASON.
WHAT WOULD IT MEAN IF LeBRON
WERE MORE TRANSPARENT ABOUT THE
VACCINE OR ENCOURAGE OTHERS TO
ACTUALLY GET IT?
>> WELL, I THINK IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL IF HE ENCOURAGED OTHERS
TO GET IT BUT HE HAS A RIGHT NOT
TO DO THAT.
YOU KNOW, YOU CAN'T FORCE
EVERYONE TO DO WHAT YOU THINK IS
CORRECT.
YOU KNOW, SO PEOPLE DO HAVE THE
RIGHT NOT TO PARTICIPATE IN
USING THE VACCINE BUT IF THEY'RE
GOING TO DO THAT, THEY SHOULD
NOT PUT OTHER PEOPLE AT RISK
BECAUSE THEY MIGHT BECOME
CONTAMINATED.
THERE ARE CHILDREN AT
I WANT TO ASK YOU ONE MORE
QUESTION AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT.
YOU'VE WIN ABOUT THIS, QUOTE,
THOSE WHO PROMOTE MORE HAVE
BLOOD ON THEIR HANDS.
SPREAD IS THE KIND OF SELECTIVE
SCIENCE WHITE PEOPLE USE TO JEFF
ENSLAVING BLACK PEOPLE.
ELABORATE ON THAT, PLEASE, SIR.
>> THE MORE IGNORANCE THAT'S
SPREAD AROUND THE EASIER IT IS
TO CONFUSE PEOPLE ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
SO PEOPLE WHO DISLIKE BLACK
AMERICANS AT ONE POINT REFUSE TO
GIVE THEM TREATMENT.
IN THIS INSTANCE, WE HAVE PEOPLE
THAT ARE TRYING TO CONFUSE THE
ISSUE AND HAVE PEOPLE NOT USE
THE AVAILABLE TREATMENT BECAUSE
OF WHO KNOWS WHAT REASON.
BUT WE CAN'T LET THAT BE
SOMETHING THAT PULLS US BACK.
WE HAVE TO EDUCATE OURSELVES SO
THAT WE UNDERSTAND WHAT IS BEING
OFFERED.
THESE VACCINES ARE SAFE AND THEY
ARE EFFECTIVE, AND WE HAVE TO
FIGHT THIS VIRUS AS A GROUP.
WE CAN'T HAVE CERTAIN PEOPLE
FEELING, WELL, I DON'T HAVE TO
DO THAT.
THAT'S INSANITY.
>> I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
YOU POINT OUT THAT THEY CONFUSE
THE ISSUE, ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO THE TUSKOGEE
EXPERIMENT.
IT'S NOT LIKE THEY WEREN'T
INJECTING AFRICANS, THEY DIDN'T.
THOSE THAT THEY DID INJECT GOT
BETTER.
>> THANK YOU, KAREEM.
I ENJOYED THIS.
>> THANK YOU.
WE NEED PEOPLE LIKE YOU BEING
WILLING TO POI